19 novembre devant la prison d'état de
californie près de san francisco le
célèbre rappeur snoop dogg lance la
campagne pour sauver tous qui pour
sauver stanley williams l'exécution est
prévue dans 24 jours plus de mille
personnes sont devant les portes de la
prison en californie on n'avait jamais
vu ça
qui n'est pas un mec comme il inspire
les autres ils m'inspirent et je sais
que moi j'aspire des millions de gens
additionnez tous là ça fait beaucoup de
millions de gens inspirés par ce qu'il
fait
voilà ce qu'on va faire maintenant je
veux que vous leviez deux doigts comme
ça et quand je racontais ça va changer
dans un état où les opposants à la peine
de mort seraient moins de 30% le cas
tout pile williams est devenu un symbole
dans ce ghetto savent ça drôle l'un des
quartiers les plus pauvres de los
angeles on connaît bien installé
williams il ya 25 ans il y régnait en
maître
cofondateur du gang des crips il
contrôlé par la violence et la terreur
la vente de la drogue
à dix jours de la date prévue de son
exécution les leaders de la communauté
noire sont mobilisés depuis quelques
jours la colère gronde stan lee williams
est considéré avant tout comme un martyr
la victime d'un système judiciaire
raciste c'est un ancien compagnon de
route de martin luther king qui prend
maintenant la parole
le système de la justice criminelle est
lui-même criminelle
il faut bien comprendre ça
je le dis en boucle et les gens pensent
que je suis fou mais non ce n'est pas un
hasard si
99% des procureurs de l'état de
californie et les chefs de la police
tous blancs sans exception veulent que
william se meurt le 13 décembre
ce n'est pas forcément parce qu'ils sont
mauvais
mais ce sont des hommes qui admettent un
système qui est lui-même crie ménez et
ils ont une part de responsabilité dans
la criminalité du système judiciaire en
californie et aux états unis
ce livre est excellent et je vais le
lire
dana blanchard fait partie du mouvement
contre la peine de mort aux états unis
la peine capitale a été rétablie en 1976
il y à quelques heures seulement le
millième condamné à mort a été exécuté
en caroline du nord tokyo williams le
prochain sur la liste est donc devenu un
symbole l'ancien chef de gang a écrit en
prison des livres pour enfants contre la
violence et a même été proposé à
plusieurs reprises pour le prix nobel de
la paix puis de conversion à la non
violence que le mouvement contre la
peine de mort a mis en avant mais qui
déclenche la polémique
il ya une pression réelle sur les médias
qui ont vraiment suivi cette affaire
certains ont essayé de salir stan dans
les médias ce sont ceux qui veulent
qu'il soit exécuté comme la police de
los angeles
les gardiens de prison ont dit des
choses assez moche comme oui il dirige
toujours les crips
on fait tout ce qu'on peut pour
contrecarrer ces attaques et continuer
de répéter la vérité sur stanley
un condamné à mort peut-il se racheter
aux yeux de la société américaine
surtout si les noirs 24 ans après la
condamnation à mort de stan lee williams
et à quelques jours de son exécution à
la prison de saint quentin la question
déchaîne les passions dans la société
américaine
dimanche 4 décembre depuis quelques
jours en permanence des activistes
religieux opposé à la peine de mort pris
devant les grilles de la prison
la rédemption de stan lee williams eux
ils y croient et ils espèrent que dans
un pays qui revendique haut et fort ses
valeurs chrétiennes l'argument portera
il nous manquerait plus que n'importe
quel autre condamné à mort
il a une envergure en termes de médias
que les autres n'avaient pas
ça ne fait aucune différence
c'est un être humain il essaye de
refaire sa vie du mieux qu'il le peut
nous croyons labonté en la bonté
potentiel de chaque homme dans sa
divinité
dans la soirée à san francisco dans un
cinéma projection du film rédemption ce
film sorti en 2004 raconte comment
stanley williams le chef de gang s'est
transformée peu à peu en apôtre de la
non violence c'est l'acteur jamie foxx
qui incarne tout qui j'étais le roi des
crips
regarder mon royaume maintenant ce n'est
pas une école de gladiateurs
ici vous ne prouvez rien
cet endroit ne fait pas de vous un homme
regardez moi
le film est projeté tous les jours un
peu partout en californie des stars
d'hollywood font parfois le déplacement
comme danny glover
touquet williams a réussi sa grâce à son
incarcération
sa façon de vivre
la façon dont il a accepté tout la
douleur toute la colère que la société
projetait sur lui en transformant tout
ça il a réussi à offrir une autre vision
du monde à nos enfants
une vision qui les sauvera peut-être
c'est d'une immense valeur
une valeur humaine
une valeur sociale
nous devons plaidé pour ça nous engager
et y aller
harry belafonte susan sarandon
l'archevêque desmond tutu prix nobel de
la paix de nombreuses personnalités
demandent que toute qu'ils soient
graciées barbara becnel ancien
journaliste écrivait un livre sur les
crips lorsqu'elle a rencontré stanley
williams en prison en 1993 depuis ils
ont écrit ensemble des livres pour les
jeunes contre la violence et aujourd'hui
c'est elle qui mène la campagne pour
persuader arnold schwarzenegger le
gouverneur de californie de commuer la
peine de mort en peines de prison à vie
merci à tous d'être là aujourd'hui et ce
soir
avant de parler je voudrais vous faire
une surprise avec stanley touquet
williams
à l'ostal
voyons si on y arrive
l'asie chan
gement tendu
tu entends ça stan
ce qui ne prend pas en la miséricorde
divine sentiront votre chaleur votre
humanité
je veux vous faire part de toute ma
gratitude et de tout mon amour
votre soutien sans faille votre foi
convaincront de votre bonté tous ceux
qui ne croient pas on veut
je vous envoie toute ma gratitude et
tout mon amour
tous ensemble cherchons la paix merci
c'est dans ce centre que barbara becnel
travail aujourd'hui elle dirige une
association qui diffuse les livres de
tous qui auprès des enfants des ghettos
ceux qui vivent au plus près des gangs
en 1993 la rencontre entre la
journaliste et ou qui a été déterminante
pourtant au tout début barbara a des
doutes sur la sincérité de celui qui
était le plus grand chef de gang en
prison
je voulais aider quelqu'un à écrire des
livres pour enfants alors que je pensais
qu'il était coupable de meurtre parce
qu'à l'époque c'est ce que je croyais
il m'a fallu du temps fallait que je me
sors de ce dilemme
alors j'ai monté des tapes projet avec
lui et j'ai vu l'impact de son travail
sur les enfants et je me suis dit ok ça
marche il est tellement sincère je veux
faire ça avec lui parce que je suis sûr
que ça peut vraiment aider
les livres de tous qui ont été diffusés
dans les écoles aux états unis mais
également en afrique du sud pour son
action auprès des jeunes contre la
violence stan lee williams a été nominé
à quatre reprises pour le prix nobel de
la paix par un comité d'universitaires
de californie
c'est le gouverneur qui prend la
décision de faire exécuter ou de gracier
stan en décidant de l'exécuter ce que le
gouverneur dit c'est qu'il condamne des
dizaines de milliers de gosses à la mort
et à la destruction
mardi 6 décembre derniers préparatifs
pour les avocats de stan lee williams
dans moins de 48 heures ils seront face
au gouverneur pour demander la grâce ces
jeunes avocats travaillent pour de
grands cabinets ils ont été mis à
disposition gratuitement pour défendre
l'un des plus célèbres condamnés à mort
des états unis le temps presse et il
n'arrive pas à obtenir l'autorisation de
filmer en prison une dernière
déclaration que veut faire tout qui
je veux voir si la prison va me rappeler
mais ils ont dit non non et non
non vous ne pouvez pas filmer
non vous ne pouvez pas apporter de
caméras
non
qu'est-ce qui a pu nous faire croire
qu'ils accepteraient ils ont déjà dit
oui dans le passé c'est sur un dvd qui
sera présenté à arnold schwarzenegger
que les avocats ont préparé leurs
arguments pour le convaincre de gracier
stanley williams ces années de prison
williams a énormément changé
suivi des cours il a rejeté toute la
violence de son passé et il a promis de
travailler pour le futur
certains gouverneurs ont pris le parti
de ne pas accorder de grâce du train
certains ont essayé de trouver d'autres
voies
malheureusement depuis 30 ans il est
gouverneur des états unis ont plutôt
décidé que si les tribunaux vous avez
déclaré coupable il n'y avait pas de
raison de gracier c'est vraiment dommage
parce que c'est exactement à ce moment
là que la grèce devient importante
en un mot ce que nous allons dire aux
gouverneurs c'est que stanley williams a
plus de valeur pour l'état de californie
vivants que morts
les avocats ont décidé d'aller à la
prison de saint quentin pour rencontrer
stanley williams ils veulent s'assurer
que le condamné à mort est d'accord sur
tous les arguments qu'ils vont utiliser
pour le recours en grâce
devant la porte de la prison les
activistes religieux continuent leur
action ils ne louent aucune occasion
d'attirer l'attention des médias
[Musique]
ok on veut juste offrir ces petits
cadeaux symboliques vous pouvez les
prendre je ne peux prendre aucun cadeau
alors on va les mettre là devant la
porte vous pourrez les emporter on va
vous dire ce que c'est ça c'est une
couverture de survie pour être sûr de
préserver la vie de ceux qui sont dans
le couloir de la mort
vous allez pas bloquer la porte non non
non je ne peux pas prendre les cadeaux
alors on va les mettre là nous sommes
les trois rois mages
deux heures plus tard les avocats de
tous qui sortent de la prison
il veut vivre s'il veut continuer son
travail il n'a pas peur de mourir vous
avez pu filmer sa déclaration
jeudi 8 décembre sacramento la capitale
politique de l'état de californie c'est
ce matin que le gouverneur arnold
schwarzenegger va tenir une audience
privée une réunion de la dernière chance
pour les avocats de stan lee williams
qui vont plaider sa grâce mais dans le
bureau il y aura aussi les procureurs du
comté de los angeles qui réclament de
l'exécution pour la star de hollywood
devenu gouverneur de californie en 2002
la décision qu'il doit prendre est peut
être l'une des plus difficiles de son
mandat à un an des élections il doit
choisir entre son électorat républicains
traditionnellement favorable à la peine
de mort et les électeurs démocrates plus
modérée devenu la première force
politique de californie
la réunion se déroulera à huis clos et
les procureurs comme les avocats auront
chacun une demi-heure pour exposer leurs
arguments ici tout le monde le sait
arnold schwarzenegger ne fera aucune
déclaration à l'issue de la réunion il
se donnera le temps de réfléchir avant
d'accorder ou non sa grâce à l'extérieur
les partisans de stan lee williams se
sont rassemblées ce que nous voulons
c'est un endroit où on puisse entendre
ce qui va se dire
l'enjeu est trop important pour que tout
se déroule derrière une porte close
ce n'est pas une conversation privée
cette discussion doit avoir lieu en
public pour qu'on comprenne ce qui se
passe dana blanchard est institutrice
elles utilisent chaque jour les livres
de tous qui est elle veut témoigner
devant le siège du gouverneur
s'il veut vraiment transformer le
département des peines en département
des peines et réhabilitation ce qui est
l'exemple même de la réhabilitation dans
les pires conditions du monde dans le
couloir de la mort de 50 à cet homme est
devenu une voix pour la paix et nous ne
pouvons pas le priver de savoir
pendant l'audience à huis clos les
envoyés spéciaux des télévisions
américaines préparent leur prochaine
intervention en direct parmi eux foxnews
réputée pour ses positions
conservatrices la chaîne a trouvé un
témoin à charge contre stan lee williams
williams parle de sa propre conception
de la rédemption il essaye de dire je me
suis racheté alors ne me punissent est
pas ce n'est pas ça la rédemption
il a fait un gros paquet de mensonges et
il a vendu sa aux médias à hollywood
et c'est ça qu'on entend partout mais
vous savez quoi
c'est pas ça la rédemption
vous savez lors à la signification
latine de repentance c'est littéralement
changé son coeur on ne peut pas changer
son camp si on ne reconnaît pas ce qu'on
a fait de mal et il nie toujours ce
qu'il a fait donc vous avez absolument
raison
foxnews est sûre de flatter ses
téléspectateurs favorable à la peine de
mort et ils sont de loin majoritaires
on voit beaucoup de gens parlaient vous
présente qu'une seule version des choses
mais vous l'entendez pas les familles
des victimes elles sont terrifiés elles
ont peur des représailles
seul espoir c'est qu'à un moment on leur
donne une chance de s'exprimer
l'audience privée vient de se terminer
les avocats de stan lee williams vont
être les premiers à s'exprimer à la
conférence de presse
le plus grand problème c'est l'éducation
des jeunes de ce pays
au cours des 13 dernières années
dans les circonstances les plus
difficiles cette année williams et red
pour aider à résoudre ce problème
les avocats ont insisté sur la
rédemption de stan lee williams une
rédemption à laquelle n'a jamais cru le
procureur et il va le dire haut et fort
devant la presse
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait de
rédemption dans cette affaire comme
monsieur williams a été interviewé dans
6t minutes il a bien dit qu'il ne
dénoncerai jamais personne alors quel
genre de message est ce qu'ils envoient
aux jeunes monsieur williams dont on dit
qu'il a toutes leurs attentions le redis
ne dénonçaient pas ne parlait pas la
police si vous assistez un crime ne le
dit pas la police ne dit pas qui est
impliqué quel genre de message est ce
qu'ils envoient aux jeunes
dans cette affaire les preuves sont
évidentes les meurtres n'avait aucun
sens il était très violent monsieur
williams doit subir la peine capitale
pour ce crime
la décision est maintenant entre les
mains d'arnold schwarzenegger
nous sommes ici pour en appeler à la
conscience du gouverneur
s'il vous plaît ne soyez pas comme
conspire à temps son temps 11 pilotes
était gouverneur et quand le sanhédrin
n'est venu le voir après avoir accusé
jésus des pires crimes ont ce pilote a
cédé à la pression de la majorité de son
époque
alors nous demandons au gouverneur
n'écoutez pas les émissions de radio
raciste
les systèmes touquet williams vivre un
pays qui ne peut être miséricordieux ne
mérite aucune miséricorde
merci et que dieu bénisse vos âmes salam
alikoum
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dimanche 11 décembre à 36 heures de
l'heure prévue pour l'exécution les
avocats de stan lee williams tente un
dernier coup de poker
ils font parvenir arnold schwarzenegger
ce témoignage de dernière minute de
gordon brown leur iphone et lerman en
1979 et 1980 cet homme partageait sa
cellule avec un autre détenu aux glaises
but qui allait devenir le principal
témoin à charge contre stan lee williams
pendant l'incarcération avec monsieur au
gloss be j'ai vu que des agents du
bureau du shérif de los angeles ont
donnés à monsieur au gloss by des
documents concernant plusieurs affaires
criminelles il y avait des rapports de
police faisant partie du dossier
d'accusation concernant monsieur
williams c'est ce que j'ai pu lire
en parlant avec monsieur claude bille il
m'a dit qu'il avait l'intention
d'utiliser les informations de ces
rapports dans le but de témoigner contre
monsieur williams et d'autre afin
d'obtenir une réduction de peine ou de
faire tomber certaines accusations
portées contre lui ce témoignage laisse
planer un doute mais la procédure
judiciaire est officiellement close
arnold schwarzenegger n'en tiendra pas
compte
lundi 12 décembre 23h50 depuis quelques
heures tout le monde le sait le
gouverneur de californie a refusé la
grâce john baez chante pour tous qui
jesse jackson l'un des plus importants
leaders noirs des états unis président
cette veillée funèbre
même en ce triste moment pour frapper
dans vos mains pour célébrer une vie
extraordinaire trap est dans vos mains
pour stocker williams
frappé dans vos mains
tous qui nous laisse un grand héritage
il s'est repenti il a aidé les autres
c'est un bâtisseur ils nous laissent
seuls pour combattre les ténèbres pour
arrêter la violence sous toutes ses
formes préférant l'espoir au désespoir
la vie à la mort que dieu vous bénisse
je vous aime
[Musique]
stanley williams est le douzième
condamné à mort exécuté depuis le
rétablissement de la peine capitale en
californie en 1978
m
[Musique]
ils viennent d'annoncer l'exécution de
stan
c'est fini
ils ont pris la vie d'un homme mais ils
n'ont pas pris son esprit nous allons
bâtir un monde meilleur nous allons
bâtir une nation meilleur nous allons
devenir un peuple meilleur et le monde
un jour va changer stan a commencé nous
allons continuer
[Musique]